hey guys this is vibhu java
and today i'll be talking about how you
can accelerate text processing with
rapids on gpus
about me i am a data scientist and
engineer on rapids where i currently
work on building gpu accelerated data
science products
before nvidia i was a masters student at
johns hopkins where my research was
focused on
building interpretable machine learning
models for healthcare and natural
language processing
so in the presentation today we'll be
going over basics about rapids
then essentially discuss more on how
strings are
stored in rapids and what are the
primitives that we provide on these
functions
and how essentially you you can do
complex thing processing pipelines
using rapids and python
so about rapids so rapids is a suite of
open source libraries
incubated by nvidia with focus on
accelerating gpu
data science n2n we essentially provide
equivalence with a lot of pi data
ecosystems like
for pandas we have qdf which is
data frames accelerated on gpus
following the
similar api we have qml
which is the cycle learning current on
gpus we
sail very nicely with the deep learning
frameworks
and we scale out using dusk
so how are string stored in rapid so
strings essentially are stored
in rapids in qdf in our data frames as a
column
a strings column can essentially have
multiple string
have variable length strings per row
and the parallelism happens on a zoo
level
essentially each string gets its own set
and all general pandas like operations
work with these strings currently custom
landlord functions are not supported but
we are actively working towards adding
support for that
so as you can see we have a very wide
coverage with the string operations on
panels
with operations like concatenation split
light split length
is aluminum and also have a lot of
converters that allow you to go from
one d type to another with strings so
apart from the pandas like string
functions
we also have functions under nv text
so a lot of times text processing deals
with
tokens or words rather than strings
and we provide a lot of common functions
that you'll
require when you're working with text
these functions
include functions like tokenize token
counts replace token
normalized spaces engram generation
sub word tokenization and all of these
accept and return
string qdf columns so
let's now look at how with the same
pandas like api in python
we can get up to 150x speeder
when we are going from pandas on cpus to
crude af and gpu so in this pipeline
what we are doing
is we are doing very common people
system steps
like filtering punctuations lower case
conversion
removing stop words removing multiple
occurrences
of space with a single word
removing leading spaces so
like the api that we are using here are
translate lower
case conversion and strip so like these
apis
themselves really fast like it takes
only 330 milliseconds
to do translate on the gpu versus 31.8
seconds with pandas the lowercase
conversion only takes 115 milliseconds
in this case versus 5 seconds
so all these functions enable
interactive
exploration of data because snc you
don't have to wait
a minute for the pipeline to convert it
only takes a second you don't have to
wait 150 seconds
so apart from the functions
like pandas equivalent functions you
also use some of the nv text functions
that
i mentioned earlier here the functions
that we are using are
normalized spaces and replace tokens so
normalized spaces essentially replaces
multiple occurrences of space with a
single one
the place token here is used for
essentially
replacing the stop words or the commonly
earthly acclaimed words
with a white space character and as you
can see this is a very
very similar api to what you'll expect
in partners
but now it just works on gpus and is
really fast
so the functions that we discussed
before this
allows you not only to do the string
processing work but also to
help build uh more high level apis like
vectorize photostammer all in
all while remaining in python and not
writing a cuda level code or c plus plus
level code
so in our qml library our tokenizers are
written with a in a similar process
so we have vector we have pfid effector
there is a count vectorizer
we have hashing vectorizer and we also
have multi gpu support
using dusk so text factorization
currently
is up to 20 x faster than sk learn and
we also essentially support most of the
common sk learn pre-processing steps
like
stopwatch removal engram generation
filtering alpha you make characters l1
norm
l2 norm so
essentially after vectorization you can
send your
vectors into a coup ml machine learning
model and
essentially run a stand run a
traditional machine learning text
pipeline like that
but if you wanted to learn a deep
learning nfp based pipeline
which is often common nowadays for most
of the nlp tasks
you can also do that with the amazing
ecosystem that provided by dusk
rapids a hugging face pythos
tensor flow so the the process of doing
this will look like you'll do your
pre-processing on qdf
desk then you have a subword tokenizer
which is essentially follows the bird
support tokenization process
and gives you out uh takes in a kudi
f strings column gives you out qpi
vectors
and it's really fast and then those
group i
always you can essentially um
send them to your favorite deep learning
framework like pytorch or tensorflow
using a 2dl pack and from dlpac so
essentially your data never leaves a
device
and once you're done with your model you
can simply can bring them back to the
kodi air for the
and then your number functions or any
functions that you make
so the server organizer i may just
mention it's right now about 483 x
faster
than the hugging face tokenizer
so the idea here is that because like
hugging face
is really amazing and it provides you
with all the amazing models that are out
there
so essentially now hugging face and
rapids
play really nicely together and as an
example of this
i worked on a tpc xp be query 27
which is essentially a big data
benchmark query
and we were able to achieve about 5x
better performance
than the leading spark and oh when nlp
submission
so not only we as we achieve 5x better
performance
the snc was able to do list at a 10
terabyte scale factor
and achieve near state-of-the-art
performance so essentially there has
been research that has shown that the
the current bird-based models gave up to
a 10 to 15 percent left in f1 score
which is
huge and if you can do that and get a f1
score increase as well
as essentially 5x better performance
it's a win all around and all of this
essentially
is with the same tools we love this is
essentially using
hugging face dash and rapids which is
essentially the pi data
apis that are present with pandas and
sqler
and it all just plays really nicely
together
so i highly recommend you check out our
website
as well as check out our github repos
and please feel free
to raise issues or any feature requests
or any documentation requests
and give lapis for your nlp workflows
are short thanks a lot guys